European Union fisheries ministers have
moved closer toward wrapping up a major
reform of the e use common fishing
policy during night long talks in
brussels the ministers agreed by an
overwhelming majority on a council
position that should allow the EU irish
presidency to conclude these broad
fisheries negotiations with the european
parliament by the end of june we are now
i think and i hope on the verge of a
very very significant a final agreement
in terms of common fisheries policy
reform this is going to be a fundamental
reform in the way we fish the package is
aimed at bringing fish stocks back to
sustainable levels and providing
citizens with a safe predictable and
healthy food supply while rejuvenating
the fishing industry the ministers
agreed to take on board scientific
advice in setting rules for the
fisheries sector and to ensure that
fleet sizes match the size of fish
stocks they also committed to do away
with wasteful discards by obliging
fishermen to land all caches and
providing them with practical management
skills to do so new measures would be
introduced to for the regional
management of Fisheries
meanwhile EU farm ministers were briefed
on the latest developments in
negotiations to reform the Common
Agricultural Policy or cap with the
Parliament and Commission the talks
focused on outstanding issues like the
rules on direct payments to farmers the
requirements to be considered an active
farmer and schemes for young and small
farmers the minister's gave fresh
backing to the presidencies aims to
clinch a comprehensive political Accord
on the package with Parliament by the
end of June